there was a time when being pro America
was a given for politicians in both main
parties of course President Reagan put
it beautifully when he talked of a
shining city on a hill but I also loved
Bill Clinton's great line there's
nothing wrong with America that can't be
fixed by what's right with America but
this week this July the fourth we saw
that those days are gone yes we still
have a Republican president who like
Ronald Reagan is obviously proud of
America and happy to say it to celebrate
it but today's Democrats know they're
embarrassed by America far from
celebrating America they want to tear it
down and turn it into something else
that's the background to president
Trump's salute to American Independence
Day the Democrats couldn't wait to
attack it Donald Trump I believe is
incapable of celebrating what makes
America great because I don't think he
gets it he doesn't get it okay look
here's some of what the president
actually said together we are part of
one of the greatest stories ever told
the story of America it is the spirit
daring and defiance excellence and
adventure courage and confidence loyalty
and love that built this country into
the most exceptional nation in the
history of the world and our nation is
stronger today than it ever was before I
think you'll find Joe China the
president Trump gets what makes America
great better than a naka de la créme
dollars in bribes in the form of
payments to his family businesses from
America's number one enemy you are the
last person to lecture anyone on
patriotism hashtag Joe China but it
wasn't just him it was all of them how
dare you celebrate America cried the
left it's not who we are
it's just not who we are as Americans we
don't thump our chests put tanks in the
streets fly jets over the mall to prove
our strength I think you know reducing
our
nation to tanks and shows of muscle just
makes us look like the kind of loudmouth
I think it's a waste of money
you know he's having a parade for
himself putting tanks out there for
himself and if he really cares about the
men and women who are serving our nation
he'd be investing in higher pay better
housing better health care by the way
that is exactly what President Trump has
done unlike President Obama you total
charlatan Kirsten Gillibrand but the big
point is captured in that smug platitude
trotted out there by the ridiculous
erics war well and the rest of the left
these days it's not who we are for once
that phrase told us something useful
about the Democrats this week just not
the way they intended the proud
Americans who stood in the pouring rain
in front of the Lincoln Memorial to
celebrate their country on July the
fourth no that's not who the Democrats
are the millions more who watched at
home and thought finally we have a
president who loves America as much as
we do and isn't embarrassed to say so no
that is not who the Democrats are the
Democrats won't celebrate America
because their new ideology demands that
they denigrate America not least with
their reckless divisive lies about
concentration camps at the border
collusion with Russia and Hitler in the
White House today's Democrats are
engaged in a concerted effort to smear
this country at home and in the eyes of
the world when they tell you they don't
want to celebrate America because it's
not who we are believe them President
Trump by contrast laid out exactly why
we should celebrate the American spirit
he talked about on Independence Day has
driven some of the most profound human
achievements in history from medical
breakthroughs to artistic glories to
engineering and technological marvels
American ingenuity has continually
confounded what the world thinks is
possible but why how it's not just
chance or luck there are other countries
with other people just as talented and
ingenious here's my perspective as a
recent arrival it is America's greatest
achievement that has made all the others
possible and that is the genius
framework constructed by the founders
and expressed in the founding documents
all in service of that simple but
revolutionary idea Liberty under the law
it's the guaranty of individual liberty
but gave the Pioneers the confidence to
set out into the unknown
they gave the entrepreneurs the belief
they could build something better that
convinced communities they could govern
themselves power to the people
decentralized and limited government the
rule of law these are the foundation of
the American spirit and they have paved
the way not only for America's long
lasting democracy but also our
world-beating
economic system in which investment
innovation and above all success are
rewarded not punished and look at the
difference it makes when we have an
administration that believes in those
American economic values another
incredible jobs report last week incomes
rising fastest for those who are left
behind under the Democrats record low
unemployment and a fairer economy for
example the gap between white and
african-american unemployment has shrunk
by nearly a half since 2016 the Obama
years gave us lower growth and higher
inequality with president Trump's
pro-america economics we have the exact
opposite higher growth and lower
inequality but those facts don't matter
to the Democrats they've been captured
by an extremist ideology that is
fundamentally anti-american you saw it
at their debates the other week and it
connects everything their economic
policies environmental policies health
care policies and yes their hysterical
reaction to president Trump's salute to
America not celebrating America but
denigrating America not power to the
people but power for themselves and the
bureaucratic elite not decentralized
government but everything controlled
from Washington DC the Democrats don't
want limited government they want
endless relentless extravagant
intervention by an all-knowing
all-seeing all-powerful state and here's
perhaps the biggest change from the
Democrats of the past
today's Democrats don't even want the
most vital element of the Ameri
and inheritance the rule of law at their
first presidential debate almost all of
the 2020 candidates backed the
decriminalization of illegal immigration
on Wednesday one of them Cory Booker
escorted migrants towards the US border
himself even President Obama's former
homeland security secretary now says the
Democrats are effectively for open
borders the Democrats point to the
Statue of Liberty and say that
immigration control is an American but
they get one vital thing it's not just
Liberty its Liberty under the law and it
is their blatant thuggish assault on the
rule of law that is truly an American
let me end on a personal note about
America I'm an immigrant here just as my
parents were in England after they fled
communism in Hungary
I've always been Pro immigration how
could I be anything else but it's
especially those of us who believe in
the virtues and benefits of immigration
who should want to see it properly
controlled because public consent for
immigration depends on government
control of immigration that's why
immigration has to be done the right way
according to the rules that's certainly
how I've done it since I moved here with
my family seven years ago and I thought
this July the fourth weekend was a good
moment to let you know that I've now
begun the process of applying for US
citizenship I cannot tell you how much I
appreciate the opportunities this
country has given me and the Welcome
you've all shown me and now I'm looking
forward one day to celebrating
Independence Day as an American if
you'll have me that is